are we ready
yeah i think we should start okay great
good um
welcome everyone to our um thursday
dmice research conference uh kicking off
i guess we're kicking off the uh
the winter quarter and
today's presentation will um be a
clinical informatics journal club
that is sometimes moved into this slot
when
um the slot is otherwise open um
i uh just just before we start
i would encourage everyone to
let us know if you want to present or if
you know of someone who
you think might want to present even
from another institution
uh we're trying to do that it's one
kind of silver lining of the pandemic as
people don't have to travel all the way
and we're trying to line up a few
outside speakers
and then also i just want to as i
always do lately encourage people to
take advantage of the offer to get the
covet 19 vaccine
and there's also going to be some
opportunities for people to volunteer
to take part in the big
vaccine efforts as soon as more supplies
arrive from
federal government um and you'll be
hearing more about that
so anyways today's uh speaker is
dr uh benjamin collins who
most of you know he's a first-year
clinical informatics fellow in our
program
he is a physician and trained in
internal medicine at temple university
in philadelphia
and um also during that time earned a
master's degree in urban
bioethics he has broad interests
in ehr design medical education health
technology ethics
and addressing health disparities so
he's going to
present this article to us and i'm sure
there will be time for
uh discussion when he's done presenting
so go ahead
ben good morning everyone uh thank you
for
attending the journal club today and
thank you dr hirsch for the introduction
i'll be presenting an article from jania
in 2020
factors associated with nurse well-being
in relation to electronic health record
use
a systematic review by oliver
nguyen and others
so to start off with what is burnout
burnout is an increasingly recognized
phenomenon in healthcare
this article uses definition from the
ahrq
that identified burnout is a long-term
stress reaction with emotional
exhaustion
depersonalization and a lack
of sense of personal accomplishment
i believe this to be a very important
topic for
four main reasons first burnout is
very common uh including within
nurses between 15 to 45
of nurses experiencing burnout at any
given time
second burnout in nurses has major
consequences
including decreased quality of care
increased health care costs and
increased
system inefficiency third
there's a large disparity in the
research on burnout and nurses
as compared to physicians although there
are
many more nurses than physicians by a
four to one ratio
there are a lot more studies of burnout
in physicians
than in nurses also by a four to one
ratio
and lastly the ehr is well known to be a
significant source of burnout
for physicians but the relationship
between ehr and burnout for nurses is
much less established
so this article set to perform a
systematic review on the existing
literature with two objectives in mind
first they intended to assess
multifactorial
and multi-level factors associated with
ehr
related indicators of nurse well-being
and second intended to summarize
potential ehr improvements
recommended by frontline nurses in the
articles
to do this the authors browsed medline
and other academic databases for
relevant articles using a set of key
terms they included articles
in english from empirical studies with
original findings that were performed
in the united states and that examined
ehr association
with well-being or burnout in nurses
the reason they included only studies in
the united states was to avoid
confounding factors that may influence
the relationship of
ehr and burnout such as documentation
link which is well known to be
very different in other countries
for the included articles they also
adapted a
risk of benefit or sorry risk of bias
assessment tool to assess the quality of
the study
from their initial search they found 4
583
potential articles from this
26 articles met the criteria based on a
review of the title
and abstract from these 26 articles
12 met the criteria based on a full text
review
the study quality of these 12 articles
were then assessed
using the risk of bias toll
and the authors determined that four
articles had a high potential of bias
and these four articles were then
excluded leaving eight articles in the
final analysis
the other of the other eight articles
four had a low risk of bias
and four had a moderate risk of bias
of the eight articles used in the final
analysis
there were five quantitative studies
one qualitative study and two mixed
method studies
the studies with quantitative components
use observational
or quasi-experimental designs the
studies with qualitative components
use surveys or interviews
two of these studies examined only one
specific
type of nurse one studying uh
evaluated burnout in rns and one
for nps the other studies did not
specify
or they studied multiple types of nurses
only one study evaluated nurses in the
ambulatory setting
and icu nurses were over represented by
the included studies
in the main article specific numbers
of representation were not reported i
hope to be able to provide more specific
details from the supplementary appendix
but unfortunately this was not
available to access for me
from these eight articles the authors
identified a number of
influences on the relation of ehr and
burnout
first they did a firm that nurses were
the nurses using ehr were more likely to
report
burnout than those who worked with paper
charts
there were conflicting findings on if
age or overall experience
of the nurses were related but some
studies did correlate
older age with increased risk of ehr
associated burnout
and nurses with more experience having
lower ehr-related well-being
the authors also found that lpns had
better ehr well-being compared to ends
other factors that were associated with
better ehr well-being
included personal comfort with computer
use
caring for adult patients compared to
pediatric patients
working on surgical floors compared with
working on
in ice use or on medical floors
there were a wide range of factors
assessed that did not
have an association with ehr related
burnout in this study
notably time spent in the ehr was not
related
and i will discuss that more in a moment
other
factors include organizational factors
such as
practice type number of clinicians in
the practice the use of scribes
nurse factors that were not related
included
sex education level prior experience
with
ehrs hours worked on a weekly basis
and shift type whether day or night
perceived ehr mental demand or perceived
effort ehr factors
that were not related include the use of
remote ehr integrated interface displays
it is significant to note that three
studies
included used epic as their ehr platform
but the other five studies did not
report
the ehr platform used at their
institution
the authors also listed several
recommendations from nurses
included in the studies these
recommendations for improving
ehr include more hr training
more access to computer workstations
improved ehr usability
improved attention to ehr workflows
for nursing tasks and increased
nurse participation in ehr designs
the authors discussed in detail a number
of their findings from the review
first it was noted how factors for
burnout differ for nurses and physicians
the factor that stood out most to the
authors in this context was how
time spent in the ehr was not associated
with ehr related burnout for nurses
for physicians there are a number of
studies that do link time spent in the
ehr with burnout
as well as the use of remote access
to the ehr outside of work hours
the authors concluded that this points
to the importance of
the amount of effort being more
important to burn out
nurses than the time of effort
they admitted that due to the variety of
roles
that nurses have in the variety of work
environments
and expectations and the lack of
specifying that in the studies it is
difficult to
really discern the effect of hr time
or nurse well-being
the authors also state that in the
discussion
that interface displays may reduce
cognitive load
leading to decreased burnout
acknowledging
also the recommendations to improve ehr
interfaces
and reduce cognitive load to do so
is suggested including digital literacy
in preparing nurses to enter the
workforce
using integrated displays to consolidate
information
to help with decision making and for
this to be supported by
organizational policies in health care
systems
they especially point out digital
literacy is a protective factor
against ehr related burnout and suggest
there should be a greater focus on this
along with ehr training
in nursing school curriculum
there are a few important limitations
highlighted by the authors
first the use of various methods and
outcomes made it more difficult to
derive
meaning from the review
because of the few relevant studies they
were also
willing to use more indirect measures of
burnout
and learning about the relationship of
ehr
and burnout for certain types of nurses
could not be
done well due to the lack of information
or nurse types
in some of the studies they also
reported a concern
about limited generalizability
in the setting that state and local laws
and policies
may have an influence on the findings
so in terms of my thoughts the the first
thing that really stood out to me in
this article
is how it highlights the importance of
nurse informaticist
guide ehr implementation
and updates avoid unintended
consequences
in ehr use for nurses and to serve as
advocates for the inclusion of nurses in
informatics projects
and research as a physician i need to be
actively aware of the workflow of other
roles
whether that is the nursing role or
pharmacy role or another role
there's also a clear importance for
organizations to be committed to the
role
that technology plays in healthcare if
computers
are necessary to perform work then every
individual
who has a need for a computer should
have direct access to one
i have been exposed to organizations
where a lack of computers led to
frustration of both
nurses and physicians trying to use
the ones that were available and
ultimately
students are the ones who end up with
the short end of the stick
where students are off of every
profession are often
kicked off of computers and given very
limited access
when the ability to use computers are
essential to the roles that they are
supposed to be learning
one concern i had about the methods in
this
review was the process for excluding
articles with a high risk of bias
it is not clear from reading the methods
section
if this was planned beforehand or if
they decided to exclude those
articles only after doing the risk of
bias assessment
another concern i had with the article
although
it may be more related to a limitation
of the articles that qualified for the
review
is there is no acknowledgement that the
second stated objective
to summarize potential ehr improvement
is not really met the articles did have
did not have much regarding
recommendations and the
results section only contains two
sentences directly
addressing this objective the authors do
provide
more recommendations in the discussion
section but these recommendations from
the authors are
inferred from some of the studies and
not a summarization of what has been
recommended by
nurses i would also note that the
recommendations included are helpful
to know but from this article it
isn't clear if those recommendations
would
decrease the risk of burnout for nurses
i suspect that would be a potential
outcome
from those recommendations but in this
study there is
no evidence to support that
i would also like to
have had more commentary on why some of
the findings
may have been related with hr ehr
burnout
instead of proposing the proposal of
hypotheses that were
sound but not necessarily supported by
the review
such as the ehr interface reducing
cognitive load it is a premise that i
agree with but
nothing in the review itself suggests
that to be the case
instead addressing questions such as
why do the authors think for example
that nurses on surgical floors had
less hr associated burnout than nurses
in the icu
or on medical floors especially giving
given some of the other findings that
were
unrelated to ehr burnout
in conclusion it is apparent that more
research is needed on the topic
there are many gaps in knowledge and
there are
few quality studies on the subject but
from what is known
it is clear that informatics can help do
more to support nurses
and reduce the risk of burnout
that brings us to the end of my
presentation
thank you and uh open for
any questions comments thoughts and also
uh would like to hear the perspective of
our guest
dina womack if she's still present
hi i'm here and thank you so much um
benjamin for that
uh great review of this
systematic review um i thought
that both your summary of findings in
your observations
were really astute so thank you for that
um as i read
the article and listen to your
summary i also was struck with
how difficult to play this issue because
the ehr is
both um a tool that you use to capture
what you did
it also is a used tool to help you plan
what you need to do
during that shift and um you know the
issue of academic load
you know covers both planning execution
and documentation of care
um i just wanted to offer like an
example that might
kind of help make this um concrete and
also
maybe give people on the call an idea of
how we potentially study this in more
robust computers
there are things in each are that like
um or there are certain tasks you need
to do that are like timed and they're
repeated
so like if the patient is receiving iv
heparin you need to
um every time that heparin rate changes
you need to draw another
blood draw within like whatever the
protocol is
usually about five hours later and you
know you would think that there would be
like a nice way that every time you
modify
the the iv rate that it would trigger
for another
lab to drop but it doesn't it there's a
prn
standing that the nurse needs to go in
and time
for like the next draw so that you can
look at the lab at the right time and
then readjust it as needed
so let's just like an an example um part
of that is because the iv
pump aren't integrated to the ehr in all
settings
and that whole logic of you know okay i
did this so now i need this timed effort
now drop this trn order at this specific
time isn't automated
and so is that an issue of of work
design of ehr design it certainly goes
well beyond any issues of user interface
design because it really
you could have a nice slick interface
for your prn that's but that's not going
to address the issue of
making sure that that prn is
intentionally dropped at the right time
to help you plan
your your work if that makes sense i
welcome other thoughts and and comments
along these lines as well
well this is bill i will uh um
chime in um nice presentation uh
and yeah dan i definitely agree i mean
the ehr such a multi-passive
thing another challenge to remember um
and you know we we do have others in in
our department
in d mice who do a lot of systematic
reviews and actually some of us
myself included have been involved in um
doing systematic reviews on informatics
studies
one of the challenges is that the
studies are not
as homogeneous as we might
ordinarily like when we're uh looking at
topics so
you know in this we years ago we did one
on telemedicine
hie i don't know if that time is here um
but um you know there's studies that
that look at
different things use different methods
take place in different
settings so it can be hard to generalize
um and so you know what you end up doing
is you know what you've
done here you can kind of look across
studies at some things but
but to your point about um you know not
not getting into some of the detail on
what you might have liked to see across
studies it's just
unfortunate uh unfortunately difficult
to do in systematic reviews but but
still i
you know overall this is a nice study
and um
you know does kind of paint a picture of
what the research
shows us in um uh you know
factors relating to uh nurse burnout and
dissatisfaction with the hr's
and and you know nurses oftentimes have
less power in the hospital to do
anything about it so it's
it's good to see this kind of research
to uh
you know really point out the problems
and
and actually maybe organizations like
amia
and their very strong and well organized
nursing informatics working group can
can be a
forceful advocate for um making sure
that nurses can deliver the best patient
care
with the ehrs that are voiced it upon
them
that's our great thoughts um there is an
effort to put 25 by five
out of um i believe columbia university
that
had they have a webinar coming up next
month that's
looking at reducing documentation burden
for nurses
that that aren't interested in um it
also was really
just emphasizing bill's point like just
the number of studies
starting from over 4 000 in the area of
nursing informatics in general
you know filtering down to eight just to
see how this
you know is an under definitely
understudied area
there's a there's a few comments in the
chat box maybe um
ben can take a look
yeah it looks like there's a number of
some work in progress here that would be
helpful to take a look at
yeah you know clearly we in the um
um you know informatics world
you know people associate us with uh the
ehrs that
people are having to use and um
so there's a lot of impetus for us as
uh leaders and and experts to um
to to make them better although
sometimes we come
we too as informaticians come up against
the forces
in uh healthcare organizations that we
can't control but it it's good for
people
it's good for us if nothing else to to
do this kind of research
to point out the problems
and and come up with solutions on how to
make things better
so so this is vishnu i had a question
for you know ben or dana or anyone
actually which is
how much do you think organizations
actually
uh you know how you know what percentage
of healthcare organizations do you think
actually pay significant
attention to nurse well-being um that's
the first part of it
and the second part of it is you know um
there are different kinds of
of clinical work forces and one of the
uh you know one of the hallmarks of the
nursing workforce is that it is
you know a unionized workforce with the
ability to make
you know large scale changes um
for the for you know for its for its
members and for the population of nurses
um has you know has the nursing
workforce in itself began to understand
some of the
stressors that are are um
are existing in you know in nurses today
because of ehr use for example and are
they taking any steps do you know of
does anyone know how
to address those first issues
with a few they recently did an upgrade
documentation system
and it was designed to help better
link documentation back to um
evidence-based practice and reduce the
effort that's required for documentation
and um they did a the rollout was
delayed
due to covid um but they did
a survey um
before the rollout and they're just now
getting ready to do
a post survey so i'm really proud of
ohsu for looking at this issue
a little more closely
yes i think from my perspective
it would be helpful to have a better
idea of
the uh nursing workflows
uh is in informatics's
um my
because my role as a physician i'm
primarily uh familiar with those
workflows
but when i've seen nurses working
um it is sometimes a convoluted workflow
um that doesn't necessarily
make for a coconut day and
i think that like it sounds like there
is
some movement on making some progress at
least here at
ohsu but i am
aware that it has pro plagued
a lot of nurses in other organizations
i think the attention sometimes goes up
and down with
um you know energy shortage and
i'm anticipating you know
the code with um
you know we we don't know yet but it's
anticipated that
perhaps people are going into health
care with all the you know recent
concerns the difficulty of getting
nurses
um you know in into training
yeah you know as as is with physicians
as well the difficulty of training
people combined with potentially the
risk of fewer nurses going into the
profession
um could we could be facing a nursing
shortage
in the next you know five years or so
that could
in addition to the kind of growing
momentum towards the topic just
really emphasize it which would be a
wonderful thing
i see a um a comment
from uh
mike k on the um
surgical services typically having
shorter clinical
notes and length of notes um
but and clear how
that's related to the nursing burnout
and i think that that is
one of the things that uh when i was
reading the paper
that i i did think about
uh that maybe there is a lower
documentation burden for the surgical
services and that could be related to
why
there was less burnout but
again without having a specific study on
that
it's not very clear
there's also a link between
documentation burden
for nursing and quality improvement
effort at the hospital
a lot of times for a quality improvement
effort you need one more data element
and we just need somebody to collect it
well who's at the bedside all the time
who's what position to collect it is the
nursing staff
and so often you know an example is you
know like
notification of critical labs well you
need to know like when was it known
and when was it communicated and when
was it acted upon and so
you know hospitals have started putting
in new forms just for nurses to quit all
of that information
where it's like something they're
already dealing with and would normally
do but not document all of those little
time stamps but
for quality improvement it's needed and
so you think of you know an organization
puts out 10 quality improvement efforts
and each one of them has a little impact
it has an
uh cumulative effect
and you know when i was prepping for
this general club you know one of the
things i realized is how little we
actually know about
nursing burnout in general if you look
at the literature there's this big chunk
about physician burnout
um provider burnout which i assume you
know includes nurse practitioners
um and then you know uh there's this
other kind of
bigger kind of subset of commission
burnout
but if you look at a lot of those those
papers they're actually talking about
physician burnout
right and and so so i don't you know i
would be very curious if
you know in your kind of you know um
travels through the literature you
actually come across
any kind of quantifiable studies that
look at
the phenomenon of nursing burnout and
what exactly
you know what is the epidemic that we're
dealing with
i have looked for good numbers i i wrote
down
then 15 to 45 because i mean that's
you know i haven't had a hard number or
like
really firm studies to point to um you
know
sometimes it'll be like a study that's
done specific to icu
or specific to whatever and so you can't
really generalize that to all of nursing
and so
i haven't had a good solid number to
refer to
i think that's that's part of the issue
right i mean unless we actually get our
hands around to grasp
the mag the magnitude of the problem how
do you
sell potential solutions um
when you look at you know the pro you
know when you look at the problem of
of physician burnout you can you can
quote numbers you can cite
you know very specific studies that have
been done that look at the magnitude of
the problem
and so you're easily able to pivot
towards
a solution that makes sense from the
workforce perspective from the roi
perspective clinical care perspective
for nurses i really struggled to find
that pivot
um how even if we do make a case
for you know ehr improvement to reduce
nursing burden
how do we sell this to our organizations
how do we
demonstrate the the human resources roi
that will come out of the consequence of
these interventions i think that's part
of the challenge of this process
um we know the problem exists but
because we're not able to you know we're
still kind of
wrapping our arms around the problem
we're not able to articulate
what the problem is in order to identify
what the solutions are
that's my take on the whole kind of
thing
i think that's really insightful and
because there's so many different
different causes then it's a more
like acidic kind of thing but
the solutions will probably be
diverse
um i also think that you know um there
is room for reading um
how documentation is involved we're in
the future it's you know you think of
devices
i mean already happening with vital
signs um and iot integration and bedside
devices but where
the nurse is more validating data that's
being answered
by other devices and then you think of
like the emergence of voice assistance
where
nurses can just do short annotations as
they're working and it kind of like
builds a note
throughout the day that if there could
in the future
it could be a lot less of this okay i
did my work now i'm going to sit down to
chart
like moving that into real time and
making it easy to do
probably will take technologies other
than the ehr
or you know integration that flows into
the ehr
in the future
i see the comments in there about
protocolization and i
agree that if you have like um
if you're in a procedural area and
you're doing something with
a patient it's like much more structured
and
you can anticipate what's going to
happen than on like a medical huge
surgical floor where you know
patients family have lots of questions
and requests and
people develop nausea and unexpected
times and
you know just of the whole variety you
can't find equipment
can't find supplies you need something
urgently from pharmacy there's a lot of
interruptions that occur
for things that are like really
unexpected and it would be very
difficult to build a workflow around
that is consistent
i think a lot of the discussion
um has pointed to
at least for me things that weren't
in this article at all in terms of
how um like for example
the idea of medical device integration
some some devices are in
some just already integrated into the
ehr
and they're um
unclear if like some of these studies
had
were in places where that's happened
and what effects that may have had on
the
results along with different things like
um the use of medical equipment
the
the relationships of the uh
um work staff um
and the it's the one that did stand up
to me was
also the um identification of the
hr uh where three studies had
uh used epic and then five studies
didn't report which which ehr was being
used
and that makes it a lot more difficult
to identify
the relationship of the ehr with burnout
and i see christine um added the link to
that 255
um project so i definitely recommend
anybody
who can uh upcoming conferences that
they have
there's also some you know movement
towards
increasing informatics competencies in
undergraduate nurses
and um incorporating it into curriculum
there's interest a colleague over at
university of portland um corey pressman
who's actually an anthropologist
very much into design is helping
incorporate design
into their integrative health it's a 300
level undergraduate course and
it's kind of exciting to see some
innovation in education
around this so that you can help the
next generation of nurses that are
coming up to be thinking about
ways that they can affect the system
alongside their basic nursing training
and i was thinking about mina's comment
that you know the nurse population is
really heterogeneous
and that makes it challenging to
generalize
potential burnout related findings and
solutions
um the physician population is also very
heterogeneous
and we've managed to you know if you
just do a literature search for
you know christine sinsky or the ama for
example just using one
you know example of the top of my head
he has been a vociferous voice for
you know um advocating for solutions to
burnout which is
which kind of spans through a multitude
of
of
of you know diverse physician workflows
and roles and so i don't know if if
the heterogeneity of nursing in itself
is a barrier as as much as the lack of
resources that have been thrown at the
problem
um that is that is the real issue here
it's not it's not
the different roles that nurses play but
but our inability to
to look at those you know to look at
those roles and address
and tailor solutions for them um i mean
i know dana's dana and i have had some
conversations about
how you can actually measure strain you
know
looking at ehr data right i mean how can
you actually try and figure out
the stress levels that nurses have you
know during ehr
by looking at data rather than you know
surveys and asking them
and doing the user kind of front-facing
thing and to me that's not just limited
to nurses that's just
so universal if we can find a way to in
so-called real-time look at ehr data in
order to identify people who are
stressed in their jobs as clinicians
and we can target some resources to kind
of alleviate some of that stress
whatever that may be
i mean how how important would that be
from a patient safety perspective
yeah there's a um a study that we're
we're
wrapping up right now um we have a
set of data about nurses perceptions
about
their shift and then we went back and
looked at more details of that shift
and then um basically are looking at
factors that differed across
high and low perceptions of workload
appropriateness and
you know something you know stood out
and are are fairly obvious like they
um you know they didn't have overtime on
the ship
they're able to take a meal break those
are things that theoretically you could
you could pick up
dynamically in real time other things
were like the number of medications that
were dispensed before noon
and having a high percentage of the work
intensity points come from medication
um popped out as a
something that is a factor that that
gives
or that is often present when nurses
said their workload wasn't appropriate
something that i have not had good
access to data on that i think would be
super interesting to study
would be this idea of like cross
coverage in nursing
where you have you know um
heavy patients or patients with very
limited mobility or
traction other things were like leaving
them cleaning them up
um you know after toileting like
requires
two sometimes three or four people
we don't have any data about like how
many of those patients are present on
the unit and how much
cross cover does needing to occur cross
coverage is also needed on meal breaks
and um there's there's really i did a
search recently and i could find
a couple of articles about cross
coverage in relationship to workload and
satisfaction among physicians but
absolutely none
for nurses
so mike says i think in terms of roi
it's still much cheaper to replace an rn
as opposed to md
so institutions will provide or not
prevention and this is very true
unfortunately but this is
the reality of it i also want to point
out that you know
we have we have placed an emphasis on
physician a you know physician use of
the ehr
since pretty much the inception of ehrs
i mean if you look at you know even
today if you look at many commercial ehr
the physician interface is a lot slicker
a lot more
user friendly than the nursing interface
um you know and this is a this is a
tradition
that we have kind of unwaveringly
followed throughout the history of ehr
is to appease
physicians as a as a group you know much
more than any other
and i think a lot of that has to do with
you know with with what mike said about
the you know the the value
cost value of physicians to a healthcare
system but whether it's you know cpoe or
cds or any of those
you know big measures we you know ehr
vendors and implementers have bent over
backwards
to accommodate physician workflows while
at the same time you know you'll have
this really you know
you know you you have a good chance that
you'll see this really slick physician
interface and the ehr and physicians
will have
multiple access points to the ehr and
the poor nurse has a screen that looks
something like dos
and it has one place in the world where
they can actually do all their paperwork
um i think there has been a systematic
push to maximize um
the the utility value of ehrs to
physicians compared to other groups and
i wonder
you know if as the literature for things
like nursing burnout increases
if that will spur a more kind of
equitable way to look at how the ehr is
being used across profession
i i like mike's point and um would
just add that it like from a health care
organization probably the priority on
reducing burn over that or burnout and
turnover that
leads over into what industry does
because
industries looking for things that their
clients want
and i've had several roles in industry
where
my role was product concepting and
coming up with
ideas of how we can use technology to
assist in the front line and of course
given my orientation um a lot of my
concepts had to deal with nursing
and it's interesting because you know
then you present it to like you know the
decision makers within
a corporation and they're like oh that's
great do physicians need this
it's so funny it's kind of a consistent
response
[Music]
there's to end on a positive note i
would like to i'm just
and um if you guys want to google that a
positive note in nursing is there's a
group called
sun seal s-o-n-s-i-e-l i believe that's
how it's pronounced and
it's basically a group of um innovators
in nursing that have found each other
and they realize that you know academia
isn't quite the right home practice
isn't quite their home they're kind of
like floating out there
and so they've created an organization
um they're
planning their third hackathon and um
it's it's a group to watch because i
think they they
really um can help um you know elevate
the voice
and um you know bring together nurses to
to focus on
innovation and even you know start
companies within
the profession that can address these
directly with first-hand knowledge of
the challenges
i just found their url um
it looks like an interesting uh site to
visit
um any other one yeah go ahead
one of the founders has a really great
ted talk that's worth
taking a look and they also publish a
book
called the rebel nurse handbook
so good
any other comments questions
okay well if not we'll um thank ben for
presenting and
and dana for her insights and all the
other
uh discussion and um we'll look forward
to seeing you all at the next
conference thank you yeah have a good
day everyone